no
[Música]
soy un hombre que fue criado para no
cambiar pañales como si tuviera una
suerte de impedimento genético para
hacerlo
por eso la cara de terror de mi madre la
primera vez que le dije que iba a
cambiar uno como iba yo a limpiar eso
que no tenía si una vagina
era natural en una familia provinciana
católica tradicional donde los roles de
género siempre estuvieron super claros
las mujeres en la cocina y los hombres
del campo a trabajar luego emigraron a
lima pero nada de esto cambió y entonces
cinco décadas después estaba yo frente a
un pañal embarrado de caca solo en el
mundo yo y todos mis temores y la verdad
es que no había mucha ciencia en dos
pega pegas que se abren y se cierran la
técnica simple de limpiar de arriba
hacia abajo y no es la inversa para
evitar alguna infección futura mirad
escrupulosamente que no haya mayores
restos y cerrar
soy un periodista y envié que dirige una
revista especializada en negocios
dirigida a altos ejecutivos y vivo en
ese mundo el empresarial donde la
mayoría de gerentes generales considera
que no existe ningún problema de
desigualdad de hecho nueve de cada diez
de ellos asegura que hay mucha o
bastante equidad de género en sus
organizaciones pero cuando tú le
preguntas a estos mismos gerentes
generales por qué en la alta dirección
no hay mujeres las respuestas que te
dicen son porque no hay talento
capacitado y porque ellas no quieren
aceptar mayores responsabilidades osea
que la culpa es de ellas
entonces vas y les preguntas a las
mujeres de cualquier orden jerárquico
qué es lo que pasa detrás de este
fenómeno y ellas se encuentran otras dos
respuestas los estereotipos de género y
los prejuicios de la alta dirección
bingo
vivo entre estos dos mundos por eso
cuando descubrimos esta data y titulamos
un artículo como la miopía de los hijos
yo me pregunté por qué algo que era tan
obvio en mi vida personal no lo era en
la suya
entonces empecé a indagar una respuesta
en mi historia personal
cuando nació julieta en abril del 2016
yo tenía 33 años y varios miedos
el miedo a ser un mal padre
el miedo a criarla en una burbuja de
privilegios desde la cual ella asumiera
que todos los beneficios que ya tienen
son los beneficios que tenemos todos
y el tercero el miedo a que algo le
pueda pasar
y no era para menos la traía a un mundo
que yo considero infame un mundo donde
las piropean a diario donde las
maltratan porque consideran que son de
su propiedad donde las golpean para que
escarmienten y donde las matan por que
las matan
un mundo o un país para ser más exactos
donde ocurren catorce feminicidios al
mes
2 feminicidios más que el promedio del
año anterior y que en lo que va del año
van 152 feminicidios sin contar las
violaciones seguidas de muerte a niñas y
adolescentes porque no son llamados
feminicidios un país donde el 63 por
ciento de las mujeres tres de cada cinco
asegura que han sido maltratadas por sus
parejas o esposos
y entonces venían mis amigos y me decían
pero a julieta eso no le va a pasar
y decía claro que le puede pasar porque
ningún privilegio va a evitar que eso
pueda suceder ni la educación que le
pueda brindar en un colegio privado de
lima ni tampoco el futuro profesional
que le auguró
porque en las oficinas la mitad de las
mujeres reconoce que en algún momento ha
sido casada allí en la oficina
no la voy a salvar de ese modo no la voy
a salvar protegiendo la la voy a salvar
tratando dándoles de las herramientas
para que ella pueda distinguir esa
masculinidad tóxica que desde niño nos
han inoculado a todos
y que está presente en nuestras acciones
nuestros gestos y nuestras palabras
quiero instalar en julieta un rol de
hombre que le permita a ella seguir ese
patrón a lo largo de su vida
incluso cuando lo haga inconscientemente
y entonces cuando te das cuenta de que
la realidad va a ser superarte a ti
mismo y a la relación con tu hija
empiezas a tomar consciencia de que de
esa realidad está tan presente en ti que
tienes que cambiar y decides cambiar
todo lo que puedas
por eso cuando nació julieta lo primero
que hice fue enfrentarme a situaciones
para las cuales me habían dicho que yo
no era capaz como por ejemplo cambiar
del pañal en los primeros días pero
también bañarla cuando su cuerpo era
indefenso pequeño y su seguridad de vida
estaba instalada literalmente en la
palma de mi mano
y entonces tomé algunas decisiones que a
la luz del tiempo considero
fundamentales
la primera de ellas fue dañarla todos
los días así de simple y durante los
primeros dos años lo que hice fue meter
el codo en el agua para detectar la
temperatura adecuada para ella y
compartir ese espacio privado y personal
de a2 y creé una conexión hermosa
pero para ello
tuve que hacer algunas cosas en el
trabajo unos pequeños cambios decirle
que no a todos aquellos
que me quisieran agendar una reunión a
las 5 de la tarde
porque porque soy bien pedir que yo
salga a las seis y que pueda ir a bañar
a mi hija
o decirles advertirles de que si me la
agenda van pues bien 5 para las 6 a las
6 en puntos yo empezaba a empacar para
irme y por supuesto que no fue fácil
porque te enfrentas a todas las caras
largas de gente que además de acusar te
sin necesariamente decirlo te juzga
porque no entienden qué proceso estás
pero también era consciente en ese
momento de mis propios privilegios el
director de un medio de comunicación en
una compañía es decir soy parte de la
alta gerencia de la compañía puedo decir
que no cuántas mujeres madres
profesionales y trabajadoras las
organizaciones pueden decir que no
siquiera tienen esa potestad
seguramente la cantidad es íntima esa
cantidad del privilegio
lo segundo que hice fue hacer algunas
modificaciones de lenguaje el lenguaje
soy comunicador tengo un sesgo eso el
lenguaje no sólo esconde significados
sino también sesgos entonces con mi
esposa decidimos eliminar una palabra
ayudar
yo no ayudo a mi esposa cumplo con mi
rol de padre porque en el momento en el
que yo le digo te voy a ayudar lo que
estoy diciendo tácitamente es que la
responsabilidad no es mía sino suya
y julieta está allí alrededor y está
escuchando todo lo que decimos desde el
primer día no subestimemos el
entendimiento de los niños ahí está y
allí estoy instalando este rol que
quiero instalar
el regalo finalmente es para mí también
porque encuentro y empiezo a desarrollar
esta relación que a 2
para mostrar
cuál es ese momento y saber de qué se
trata quiero compartirles una pequeña
carta que le escribí a julieta cuando
ella tenía un año un mes y diez días
14 de mayo del 2018 el ritual es
sencillo cerca de las nueve de la noche
ambos sabemos que es hora de dormir
hemos cenado lo mismo de preferencia
para evitar que se disguste y señale a
mí ya mi plato insistentemente con su
dedo hemos jugado armado y desarmado los
cubos infinitamente cada quien con su
función yo construyo ella destruye
la eba añado nadan patos pelotas y hasta
libros hemos cantado y aplaudido el
juego del puercoespín de colectivo
animal mínimo 10 veces solo entonces
ella bosteza por fin es hora de dormir
lo sabemos entonces decía el ritual es
sencillo
apagamos juntos todas las luces de la
casa una por una señal de que vamos a
dormir pero hoy le hemos agregado un
último paso que ella misma con su dedo
ya tiene la fuerza apague la última luz
la del cuarto de esa manera le expliqué
yo sabré que ya quiere dormir de esa
manera le insistí ella decidirá si
quiere hacerlo
y mientras caminábamos juntos a oscuras
su cabeza ya sobre mi hombro le hablé de
la libertad
hoy has apagado la luz mañana decidirá
si prefieres la música el fútbol el
voley o los libros luego si tienes novio
o novia y más tarde si quieres tener
hijos o no casarte o ser soltera para
siente no elegirás todo julieta como el
caballo rojo o el globo de bach incluso
si andas con el pelo suelto como te deja
tu madre y aunque ellos siempre te
quiera peinar
el machismo nos quita está felicidad
a los hombres nos la impide
no es la castra
y cuando yo recuerdo a mi propio padre
un hombre duro ciertamente conservador
y recuerdo el momento más feliz que viví
con el recuerdo mi cabeza sobre su pecho
cuando dormíamos la siesta era un
espacio un momento y mi padres sólo se
permitía en el terreno privado
jamás lo iba a hacer en el terreno
público
el machismo nos ataca por igual a
hombres ya mujeres
y entonces decido eliminar algunas
escenas de mi vida que yo no quiero que
se repitan en la vida de mi hija
escena 1
mi abuela nos recibe en su casa a mí ya
mi prima hermana yo tengo 10 ya tiene 8
años
y entonces porque es tarde estamos
cansados venimos de jugar toda la tarde
y nos va a servir la comida pero un
detalle le llama la atención a ella por
no servirme a mí
le está reclamando porque no cumple su
rol de mujer desde niña porque ella no
está haciendo lo que en mi familia
siempre llamamos acomedida
escena 2 hace muy pocos meses y no la
juzgo realmente mi tía
en la mitad de una reunión familiar se
da cuenta que en la mesa hay menos
sillas de los presentes en la reunión
entonces toma una decisión
fácil los hombres a la mesa las mujeres
a la sala
y yo busco julieta en ese momento
literal donde está porque quiero saber
es escuchado eso no quiero que ella
asimile eso como una verdad no quiero
que ella interprete que las cosas son
así
el machismo está presente y es el
elefante blanco que no solo está en
nuestras casas sino también en las
oficinas donde las mujeres
en promedio según la encuesta de semana
económica 10 horas más y un poco más que
los hombres en las labores de crianza y
cuidado de los hijos
diez horas más
son al año porque suman un poco más 560
horas
la cantidad de horas promedio de una
maestría que se ejecute a lo largo de
dos años
o si quieren 70 días laborables tres
meses y medio de trabajo
y en esas horas libres por supuesto
nosotros los hombres podemos tener la
ventaja de entregar de algunas de esas a
la compañía y quedar bastante mejor como
pretendemos que los jefes
quieran contratar las a ellas que
técnicamente son menos productivas como
podemos asegurar
que existe una cancha nivelada para
nosotros como podemos hablar de esto
extraño que llaman meritocracia
el problema es que el trabajo de casa no
es considerado un trabajo hasta que te
das cuenta
hasta que una mañana llegas tarde a la
reunión con el dueño de la compañía
y le tienes que explicar que has tenido
que dejar a tu hija
en la guardería está hecho un berrinche
de padre y señor mío durante media hora
de camino entre tu casa y la guardería
un llanto intenso que no sabías cómo
diablos parar porque le sacaste todo lo
que había en la mochila pero al final
dijiste por qué no le doy este pan con
queso que me iba a desayunar y que no me
desayuné
y cuando le tienes que explicar esto al
dueño de la compañía y no sabes si le
importa una o no entonces te das
cuenta
yo no les quiero decir con esto
de que hemos logrado una comparen
talidad perfecta en mi casa
que tenemos los roles compartidos
perfectamente definidos para nada
ha sido mi esposa la que ha hecho el
mayor sacrificio en mi casa
lo que sí les vengo a decir es que un
día desperté y me di cuenta que era un
papá pingüino
los expertos en mercados no están
definidos ya bajo ese nombre
en relación a estos animales que crían a
los hijos mientras las hembras van en
busca de alimento afuera
y somos 253 mil papás pingüinos en el
perú según ipsos y hay que decirlo con
orgullo vamos en franco ascenso
somos una pequeña legión de hombres que
estamos dispuestos a trabajar más en
casa y que a cambio logramos una mayor
relación emocional con nuestros hijos
el 91% de nosotros todavía trabaja
contribuye económicamente a la casa
no es verdad por supuesto que nos
dedicamos enteramente a ella
pero estamos iniciando un cambio un
pequeño cambio significativo
pues bien les decía al inicio de esta
charla no sé si lo recuerdan
que habíamos titulado un artículo como
la miopía de los tíos y que yo no
entendía porque algo que en mi vida
personal era tan obvio no lo era en la
vida de ellos
creo que ya tengo una respuesta
no ven el problema porque no lo tienen
que afrontar
felizmente están sucediendo cosas somos
muchos los que estamos luchando
silenciosamente y saben qué
faltan manos
y cada uno de ustedes desde la posición
en la que están desde sus momentos de
vida pueden sumar
con pequeñas acciones
yo no quiero que mi hija sea golpeada
maltratada violada o asesinada
julieta tiene dos años y medio
y le encantan los perros
y desde que descubrí que le encantan los
perros que a mí nunca me han gustado
los veo en todos lados
y salimos con julieta al parque a buscar
perritos y allí están por decenas yo
nunca había visto esos perros y los
perros no están allí para julieta
yo los he empezado a ver
la realidad es la realidad que cada uno
quiere ver los hijos no son los únicos
miopes los somos todos el elefante
blanco está en medio de esta sala entre
nosotros y sólo hay que abrir los ojos
decidir abrir los ojos para darse cuenta
de que está aquí
[Aplausos]
[Música]